more thoughtful calm and wonderful human
being my name is Brett silver pastor at
the table in Sachse Texas and Before we
jump in a day I just need a moment to
mourn my Cowboys why they are so there
underachieving Jason Garrett has to go
he does it's been like what a decade
yeah done a rent over so this is part 4
of our I think it's part for something I
don't know it doesn't matter but we're
going through a series unlike relational
conflict what to do when relationships
break down and so today I want to talk
about an idea that's been popularized by
that a family therapist named Edwin
Friedman it's known as relational
triangles and this is honestly it's it's
fascinating it's really it's describing
sort of it a deeply just human phenomena
relational phenomena that we all we both
perpetuate and in many ways we are
victims of it so I'm gonna give you sort
of he'll talk about it in the victim
scenario since that'll be less
accusatory so let's say Susie Susie sure
Susie gets offended by Jim and her
feelings you know really hurt but does
she go directly to Jim to talk about it
no of course not that would make too
much sense instead what does she do she
goes to Rachel and she says she wouldn't
believe how Jim treated me Wow
I am I mean I'm shocked I'm I'm offended
and of course during a Rachel she's a
super caring person and so she says
my goodness I'm so I'm so sorry that
must be so hard and then Susie says you
wouldn't believe how hard it is and then
Susie proceeds to verbally process with
Rachel for the next half half an hour
and the whole time Rachel's like kind of
increasing the comfortable right okay so
what's happened in this scenario Susie
has triangle Rachel now why does this
happen in what issues arise when we do
this first I think we triangle because
it acts as a release valve of sorts
right when Susie has an issue with Jim
she kind of feels all that eggs but it's
scary and difficult to talk with Jim in
fact Susie would rather talk with anyone
in the world about her pain other than
the one person who can actually do
something about it right so what's new
so she talks with Rachel and then lo and
behold when she talks with Rachel she
feels a little bit better but here's the
problem and this is point number two
when triangled right when we're the ones
being triangle we now carry the stress
for others relationships right so Susie
walks away feeling better but what about
Rachel well now she feels terrible
in fact she's stressed because she is
worrying about this relationship right
she's now carrying the burden for in in
a sense she feels responsible for it
this leaves a point number three which
is that allowing myself to get triangle
it means that I now carry the stress for
a relationship I am actually powerless
to fix
this leads to burnout this is actually
one of the Edwin Friedman's insights he
thinks often burn out like an P brother
psyche not just I'm tired I need to rest
but burnout is like something more
chronic something deeper and he believes
when this happens it's it's usually
about triangles as opposed to just like
oh you know I worked 13 hours instead of
10 and you know for too many days so I
got burned out it's like whenever
there's legit psychological burnout
probably triangles okay
so there's a ton of other literature and
things on chronic stress in triangles I
don't want to get into all the weeds of
it but I'll just simply say that this is
often why leaders and highly responsible
people experience Brown because they run
around allowing themselves to be
triangle all day long they're highly
responsible so they're taking
responsibility for not just their lives
lives and their relationships and yet
these are lives and relationships that
they can't actually control right no can
you control you and that's it right so
the triangle person is powerless and yet
they are stressed and by the way this
crap can put you in an early grave and
furthermore if you are the peacemaker in
your family watch out watch out you're
probably getting triangles freaking all
the time right so your your sister calls
you to process about mom and then mom
calls you to process about the sister so
and again this is not only it's
stressful for you and it's actually bad
for them this leads me to point number
four when you allow yourself to be
triangles um you are actually ensuring
that others never mature they never
mature why because you're standing in
the way because people grow up by
dealing with their
right bye-bye learning to take
responsibility for their own hearts
their own emotions their feelings by by
their with their lives right and
learning to have hard conversations
where they name how others have heard
them this is part of how they mature but
coming back to our story
when Rachel allows herself to be
triangle right because she is allowing
it she I mean it would be easy to say
like she's a victim but Rachel couldn't
stop Suzie be like hey so right and so
when she allows herself to be triangle
she thinks she's being a good friend to
Suzy but actually she's doing Suzy and
Jim a disservice this is really exactly
the advice Jesus offers in Matthew
chapter 18 verse 15 when he writes and
they look it up here if another believer
sins against you i biscuit hide X of
another believer sins against you go
privately and point out the offense if
the other person listens and confesses
it you have won that person back in
other words Jesus saying don't triangle
people go right to the source okay so in
conclusion I want you to take a moment
like take a quick inventory of your life
are their relationships coming to mind
where you are either being triangled or
are trying galine others I'm at you tune
in tomorrow or probably not tomorrow
Tamar's Christmas may be in a few days
I'm definitely taking tomorrow off we're
all unpack how to get out of relational
triangles and yet hopefully that'll be
helpful so that's all for today if you
like this video please click the like
button subscribe share it etc etc love
y'all grace and peace
you